welcome welcome back everybody thank you
very much for returning for your
patience just now you are the hardcore
still here um we have just exactly half
an hour for this panel because SVT the
television take us off the air in half
an hour and before we start I just
thought it'd be nice to give a round of
applause to the crew here who have
magically transformed this room from one
to three and back to one
so this is the concluding panel we've
called it emergent conclusions and with
so much that's happened today there
isn't a chance of summarizing what we've
been through but the audience members
and the panelists have only had a chance
to listen to one-third of what's
happened this afternoon you've missed
two thirds of it and so what I'm hoping
to do is to use this opportunity just to
bring to the fore some thoughts that
came out of some of the discussions and
so I'm going to go through the panels
one by one and ask my panelists here on
stage to give their thoughts on what was
said and I don't at all ask them to
summarize everything I just want them to
pick some things that they thought were
interesting and then I've also got
microphones out in the audience and i'm
going to call upon the panelists and if
they like the moderators who were on the
other panels or on the powers that we're
going through to make comments as well
same idea anything that they thought was
interesting just worth sharing with the
audience especially the audience who
hadn't been in the room so let's go
numerically so start with panel 1 a
which was on the promised land of
genomic medicine where can the science
take us Eric and Joe were both on that
panel so Joe bilstein would you like to
start by just giving us a thought or two
okay so on the title was the promised
land of genomic medicine and and I wrote
three things down that I thought i would
tell you about or one we concluded that
in order to maximize the power and
strength of of genomics for medicine it
was very important that the phenotypes
of patients the clinical manifestations
of different illnesses be characterized
and split into different groups and that
would be the way that one could then
relate that to the to the genome
information and that would get us to the
right mechanism of the disease which is
ultimately what the pharmaceutical
companies need in order to develop an
effective drug if one examines a list of
the top 10 selling drugs in the world
today virtually every one of them have
depended on 10 to 20 to 30 years of a
biochemical and physiological and cell
biological studies in order to have
arrived at the right target so that's
what I that was one important point that
was a discussed today and the second one
something that I didn't know that came
out from a Bert vogelstein or who was on
our panel and only about five percent of
patients with cancer participate in
clinical trials so I think that's a
really sobering statistic when one
thinks about trying to develop new drugs
based on genomics it what has so few
patients that have cancer that actually
participated in the clinical trials and
then the third thing that came up our
Goran Hansen our panel leader asked each
of us would we want to have our genome
sequence and there was six of us on the
panel and the answer was unanimous none
of us thought there was any reason to
have one's genome sequenced at the
present time the only reason would be if
if we should be so unlucky to get cancer
then then it would be important to get
the cancer that's removed from the body
sequence and that may help in the
therapy but the general feeling was one
if you get your genome sequence you'll
learn about your sex whether you're male
of female you'll learn your geographic
roots in fact if you are if it turned
out the gene said you're from Sweden you
can infer that you'll be tall and blonde
which you would not be able to figure
out from the genome and then I actually
said I think there's one gene for red
hair the this you might be able to buy
but there's very little you'd find a lot
of statistical facts
that may or may not help you understand
your disease or your physician so those
are the three that I came up with Eric
may want to embellish on thank you I
should hasten to add that anybody can
anybody on the panel can comment on
anything that anybody else says but Eric
do you want to go ahead well I'll just
pick up from where Joe it left off there
we talked about how in a sense science
just keeps moving the bottleneck further
down it expands the pipe of what's
possible but it always confronts some
bottleneck so now we're in this
situation where genomics is handing off
hundreds and hundreds of interesting
hints and leads but those are not
targets those are not pharmaceutical
targets and we need the same energy that
has been brought to molecular biology
and genomics being brought now to
biochemistry and cell biological
characterization to rapidly speed that
up to think if we got of a genome
project why not a cellular circuitry
project you know it sounds crazy to us
old folks but to the young people
they'll be thinking about how do we make
that stuff go faster and more systematic
I totally agree with Joe about the
importance of patient phenotypic
characterization being critical and i
want to add the sharing of information
particularly as we're going to be
collecting genomic information on so
many patients around the world we either
will share that and get enormous benefit
consistent with privacy by sharing it
and seeing that people who had this
unusual phenotype here there and there
had something similar in their genome
and there's no way to know that without
sharings we've got to figure out how to
be sharing that information and finally
a theme that emerged was realistic
expectations that even the most powerful
scientific revolutions the infectious
disease the antibiotics that were cheap
and broadly available was a 75 year
process and you know one should not for
a moment limit in any way with the
eventual impact of all this will be but
one should always be cautious about
promising that that that impact will be
available next year or even this decade
thank you very much indeed and it we're
here we're blurring the boundaries
between 1a and 1b and that makes all
time
a second syllable word I said it makes
perfect sense because you really can't
separate of course the prop that the the
science from the delivery of the science
to to medicine one thing that came up in
in 1b was the idea that the the clinical
trial procedure is is moving its
shifting away perhaps from richer
nations towards poorer nations emerging
markets and I know that domick Barton
you had some thoughts you wanted to
share on that yeah I think we we see
there's an increasing offshoring if you
will of the research to do the clinical
trials we're seeing this in China in
India Abu Dhabi with diabetes and I
think that I'm not sort of saying I'm
against regulation but there's I think a
more utilitarian view that's looked at
when people will say well we let's
aggregate the information we can get it
in a cheaper manner and we're willing to
understand what the risks are and where
we are because the cost of not doing it
is even higher for then doing it and so
we do see pharma companies that are
increasingly offshoring that to to
emerging all developed if you like
health care system yeah absolutely i
mean again I think just I think that the
clinical trials are the bottleneck again
with all of this great science that's
being done the getting the trials to be
able to be done is the bottleneck and I
think we're seeing more openness
especially with rising health care costs
if you look at just what China is going
to be facing over the next 10 to 15
years it's going to be humongous and so
there's a lot of interest in trying to
encourage make it as easy as possible if
you will for that sort of rd to be done
there thank you I wonder whether ticky
pang I don't know where he is in the
audience but other I wonder whether he
with 13 years of experience with the wh
0 would like to reply to that comment
yeah I think doc Dominic's made an
important point I just like to to just
add to it that in addition to that was
at risk for genetic disease could that
be corrected and there were two
interesting points made in the
discussion of that first all the
panelists probably agreed that that
would be possible seems like science
but would be possible in certain cases
in the future there are obvious ethical
questions involved but at least
technologically it would be and the
second point not point brought up by
maryclaire King was what can be done now
which is equally science fiction which
is to take using PGD pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis take one cell from an
embryo figure if that ever figure out if
that embryo carries the disease gene and
if it does substitute it with another
embryo thereby making sure that the
child that's born does not have the
genetic disease and that would have
certainly seemed like science fiction
science fiction 20 years ago but it's
now practiced routinely at least in in
certain places for certain diseases it's
really miraculous thank you but thank
you okay um i think we probably given
time better move on to stream to to a
was the panel on genetics in agriculture
and the environment and christian
andersonville hard was part of that
panel so would you like to give us a
initial thought we discussed GMOs and
their use in aquaculture and it was
pointed out that this is just one way of
breeding crops to increase yields and
also to make the food more healthy and
allow sustainable agriculture and it's
not more than that but it's very
important in because crops which are
resistant to diseases do not need
spraying so we can save on pesticides
and this also would provide a more
healthy working condition for the
farmers as well as also for the
environment and I think this is one very
important aspect which which we touched
upon people were asking whether they
have had dangers and I think there have
been so many studies done now worldwide
that there is actually no reports on any
any
cases where GMOs have been dangerous for
human health and so this is probably not
the issue which is important but the
issue is the acceptance by the public
and this is something we were really
puzzled about because in there are so
many I'm in countries where these demos
are used and they're very successful and
they are also economy economically used
and this is important I mean it's not
only that you save pesticides but it's
also that it's also to ensure that the
that the yield is better for the farmers
because that also increases their belt
and we have learned also in this
morning's sessions that wealth is
related inversely to numbers of children
and I mean this is now perhaps a bit
far-fetched but in in India for example
the cotton is I think eighty-five
percent of the cotton farming is now
with GMO and these are small farmers and
their their their economical success is
increasing and this certainly has a big
impact on the country and this is one of
the benefits which I think are very
important I myself and I may say that
again and I think we should aim for a
sustainable agriculture where we use the
soil which is really good for
agriculture and use it as efficiently as
we can and try to put back on natural
conditions all the soil which we have
cultivated but which is not very
efficiently cultivated now and this is
happening in sort of reen a chiral
ization is called and then rather put
put put all the energy and getting
higher yields on the from the good soil
and leaving the other things for nature
in order I mean also to avoid taking
more land into culture like cutting down
rain forests and so on to increase the
to increase the space we can use for
agriculture in order to feed the
included increasing population did I
leave anything out maybe some other
people that we have discussed for half
an hour so one hour and more so I cannot
summarize
I don't I don't intend to ask you to
Sergei Jessup's just well I wasn't on
the panel but I was listening and one of
the things that came out was there's
gradations of gmos start with Harvard
hybridization crossbreeding that's
genetically modified but of course the
public thinks of GMOs as using modern
molecular biology techniques but it was
pointed out that we would do things with
radiation or chemicals that would that
have been going on for quite a while to
get mutants and then select these plants
these phenotypes that we desire and
there's also gradations in there where
if you can do genetic modification
within a species strain versus a trance
drain and then of course then there's
and what would the economic benefits be
if you could get crops that could be
bused with some essential vitamins as an
example that could really be of great
benefit and so there were a number of
other things that made the discuss tried
to make the disc watch more nuanced then
it's a yes or no it's better good mm-hmm
Thank You Dominic did you want to make
any comments no I think it was well said
the gradation point I mean we did
emphasize to that there's we have to
create seventy percent more food just
gets back to Stevens chart in the
beginning we need to create seventy
percent more food than we have now for
2050 just given the population in the
middle class so it's it's a it's a
burning issue and we need to do more rd
there were some interesting comments on
from the audience actually of 3d meat
machines which i never heard before
Louise told us it cost twenty eight
thousand dollars a kilogram or something
for a 3d meat potatoes and raspberries
but the point around that was also just
the education and understanding about
what this means back to stevens point
and we need to do more i think to
explain to people what this is and what
this isn't and how it can benefit yeah
I'm Helga novotny's point from the
morning of understanding in fact not
understand it but engagement being key
is under light
then all these discussions I believe
does anybody want to make a point from
from the perspective of 2a from the
audience if anyone sees hands up please
oh sorry not from the audience I'm sorry
i meant from the panelist in the
audience i'm sorry there's no time to
involve the audience and discussion I'd
love to but that that would be it have
to be a different day okay to be oh that
I'm sorry Louise I can't see you there
yes sorry I was hiding actually the one
thing I think we should add we didn't
really cover but is one proviso on the
GM debate that is important and that
concerns the areas where the original
does mystification of the crops has
taken place the area so-called developed
areas of Biological Diversity for those
crops or example the Andes in Peru I
think we should have some international
agreement that we're not going to
experiment with GM field trials in areas
that might be sensitive although the
risk is close to zero it's not entirely
zero and I think this would be a nice
easy area to get international
agreements in as a step towards more
international agreement on all kinds of
other issues of regulation of GM's was
that was that a generally agreed pointer
was that a point of discontinuity we
missed out on is that most people put a
lot of harm to GMOs which are not caused
by demons at all like massive I mean
industrialization of Agriculture and
things like that and dying of bees or
whatever I mean name it and then they
all say it's it's da Mo's and it's not
GMOs it's just a em there is this
romantic movement towards organic
farming and by or elliptical food and so
on which is very unrealistic and and
doesn't take into account how we can
possibly provide nutrients for such a
large population of human beings in
these big cities and it cannot be done
in the front yard
thank you okay Powell to be nature
versus nurture or nature and nurture
genetic determinism Helga yes it's
difficult to summarize but we had a very
engaged discussion well what is actually
now the state of the art regarding
epigenetics and there was a sort of more
technical explanation of the term and
what in particular maryclaire King
thought she found in Europe a public
more public enthusiasm for epigenetics
so this was one of the topics we covered
we also asked ourselves why there is
this why some people are afraid of
genetics as being a factor that is
irreversible in terms of creating
differences between people while
environmental factors are more malleable
and you can change environment or you
can impact on the environment to some or
other things then so it's a more
optimistic outlook on life but I really
we had gym amongst ourselves so whatever
we said jim was of a slightly different
opinion which enliven the debate and I
really wish that others should also
cover a bit of this of this panel with
others like to take a microphone Bruce
maryclaire yes ah but the moderator Matt
Ridley
thank you beautifully summarized thank
you stream 33 a human evolution Bruce
Albert's panel and yes Helga no I'm back
again you're back again now this was a
panel that covered a huge stretch of
chimed in fact Great Meadow had to step
in as well and begin with the origin of
life so for it really went back to that
point but we covered the transition Leon
detalis to humans and there were also
some dogs were very important what can
we learn from the breeding of dogs and
then towards the end there was a sort of
trance humanistic questioning you know
if we keep on doing all these things
will we change human nature as we
understand it now and as we feed we are
human now so that's my very brief
summary yes very nice thank you but
Santa Craig anybody want to make a
comment to back it I can't really see no
hands no they obviously they obviously
trust you trust your summary thank you
keep the charge give each I'd never hear
hear yellowcake great man oh sure Craig
melon it was a great session I just want
to add that that you know the I think
one of the themes was that
we have the ability now to at least in
animals to modify germline and there was
a lot of discussion about that and I I
think that you know it was really it was
while it's interesting it you know the
conclusion really was clearly this is
something that's not safe to do it's not
ethical and we really can't do it anyway
but it you know nevertheless it was a
really large part of the discussion but
another theme but I think more related
to the second half so I'll just say it
now of the stream was how the human
genome has really empowered model
systems to help decipher the function of
the human disease related genes and I I
think that this is something that needs
to be really appreciated as the pressure
on funding and science funding tends to
be very translational now it's important
to keep in mind that we need to keep
funding basic science because it's the
engine that really is the rosetta stone
that helps interpret the functions of
all of those disease related genes that
Eric talked about in his talk today
thank you well as we step on to the last
panel Stephen would you like to say
anything about that well there were the
first question that was posed I thought
if it's very interesting was now that we
have this genome what next where are we
going and I think many of us felt that
we know so very little we've learned so
very much and as we've learned so very
much it's a cliche I know but it doesn't
mean it's not true that there is so much
more that mug the vest and if you look
back five years ten years very recent
history how little we knew about major
discoveries and how important it is it
starts with the genome but we now know
that that's a small part of it really
happens on the whole system and the
regulatory system and how it impacts
what the cell what the organism is
really doing and so it's just part of
that yet but we're
you know perhaps 40 years ago 50 it was
the major blueprint you just follow the
instructions saluted and that was it and
it's a very different world now okay so
50 50 years on from the water the Nobel
Prize we're at a big question mark are
you asking me and if I was a fantastic
noble right Christiana would you like to
we discussed that collecting all this
information which you can do now with
the fast genome sequencing is in on the
one hand of course a big big challenge
on the other hand it does require smart
biologists to look at the data and
without this you will not gain the
knowledge you can get out of these
things and I think I've was interesting
to me that in the the other pattern
which I didn't attend two people were
asked whether they want their genome to
be sequence and everybody says no I
don't expect to learn anything about
myself from the genome and i think that
the correlation between the phenotype
and the genotype this is the critical
issue we cannot really phenotype very
well we can genotype fine they can get
the sequence no question properly done
no mistakes anymore but the fina
assessment of the phenotype in all this
background of noise in each individual
as a very very much diff a very
different genetic background is really
really tricky and it's there at this
point where they were where the model
organisms come in because there you can
do experiments you can do proper
experiments you can get large numbers of
animals and you can also control their
genetic background you can make isogenic
animals which have just this one gene
changed and then you know about the real
function of the gene you could also
identify components interacting with
this particular gene and I think on the
this is a sort of us and excursion oh
it's an indirect way to get at the at
the function of the gene but it's really
very necessary and then we discussed a
little bit about funding of these types
of approaches
and agreed that whenever the curiosity
of the scientist is high enough and the
problem is interesting enough any type
of biological research deserves funding
and not just the one which is very close
to clinical trials are very close to
human diseases and I think this was
total accepted on on the panel thank you
yes I mean this theme of the success of
the genomics and the need for
elaboration of the genome seems to have
been brought out on all the panels well
thank you very much indeed it's a hard
job to try and summarize such an
afternoon but that was wonderful it
really just remains for me to first of
all thank our sponsors who have made
today possible so I think a spider might
appear I hope could we have the next
slide yes I would love I would very much
like to thank Carl Burnett the city of
Gothenburg and wait for it the region
would here here we go vested a good land
or youth land but that was a very good I
know you could say it better
I was I was better when I practiced
before anyway thank you very much indeed
for your support and making this happen
and as last said in his introduction
next year on December the ninth we this
will all happen again on a different
theme and it'll happen in your tub or a
beautiful youtuber a lit up for
Christmas behind us and we would welcome
you all there in a year's time but for
now it just remains for me to thank all
the participants panelists who took part
and took the trouble to come to
Stockholm for this event and all the
audience who have so loyally stayed with
us through the day I hope you've had a
wonderful day and thank you all for
being here